colorado massacre has focused a new
spotlight on gun control
president biden is pushing for
legislation or perhaps something else
white house correspondent peter ducey
has our report tonight live from the
north lawn good evening peter
good evening brett president biden is
calling on congress to pass an assault
weapons
ban his party has the numbers right now
controlling both
houses of congress but he is prepared to
take executive action where he can
if there are any democratic holdouts
the united states senate i hope some are
listening should immediately pass
the two house pass bills that close
loopholes in the background check system
but that's a problem because when asked
if he supports those house passed bills
democratic senator joe manchin says no
not at all
so the white house may cut congress out
we are certainly considering a range of
levers
including working through legislation
including executive actions
no real white house action at the border
yet as new video edited by the
government shows migrants being
processed behind the same kind of chain
link fences
democrats once called cages with the
so-called cage walls
covered by a green tarp you can't treat
them humanely when they're packed in
like sardines
the feds sent a bus load of migrants to
the tiny town of gila bend arizona
with little heads up for locals
apparently somebody
in washington got the thought that we
have
a bus stop here but they don't have a
bus stop
so what happens to those migrants i
don't know just get off and become part
of the homeless
community this is ridiculous in larger
cities more than 1800 migrants with
criminal charges or convictions
have been freed by judges including 545
in phoenix 428 in houston and 195
in la those are separate from the
migrants fox has learned are being
processed and freed in the states
to me that's unprecedented how do you
release somebody to the
country without it just to appear
now i have to say they were not adults
they were not unaccompanied kids but
they were
family units it's unclear when the
president or vice president will take a
trip south
not today not funny to border state
senators
that is not compassionate that is not
giving a damn
critics charge biden's campaign trail
talk was too inviting to migrants
we could afford to take in a heartbeat
another two million people
the white house sees biden as a healer
but he's keeping his attention publicly
away from the border and on
the tragedy in boulder i hate to say it
because we're saying it so often
my heart goes out our hearts go out
for the survivors so there's a lot going
on
the white house was not planning for but
so far officials are sticking to the
schedule
as planned the president kept a
commitment in columbus this evening
delivering remarks
celebrating the anniversary of obamacare
brett peter ducey live on the north lawn
peter thanks